Nó nay, 2.5 mũn năm 2020, tông tin từ công an tỉnh Bắt Ninh. Đơn vị vừa chỉ phá đường dây bản dân năm
dọ đối văn thành, sinh năm 2020 tâm tâm tâm tâm tâm, chú tại khu đồ thị văn quán, phương
hà đông, hà đồng, hà đội, cầm đồ.
Chứ đó, 2.5 mũn năm 2020, tông cạnh rất hiện sự công an tỉnh, công an phương vó gần và công an phương
bác sang, phương hợp kìm chá hay khách sản trên địa bản phương vó gần và phương bác sang.
Phát hiện 2 đôi nữ đạo có hình viên 1 bản xâm, qua đấu tranh, cả 2 đối tượng năm, sinh năm 2020 tâm
mấy và 2 hình khu trình tư. Đều đá xí xống, hóc tập và lần việc tại Hà đội, 2 nữ có hình vi
bản xâm cho 2 phương nước có độ tùy khoảng 1 mũn vừa giá tổ nhăn là 2 phy năng chựa đồng mổ lượt mổ vừa.
Sao mỗi lần giờ, tình công, người môi giới sẽ trả cho các đối tượng 1 trựa đồng, cầm phi xí triển.
Hí các đối tượng 1 có nữ cầu sẽ lên hiện với thành qua xalô để thật bởi tập số tiền một chựa đồng bảo hình tức chuyện khoảng,
sau khi 1 bản thành công, các đối tượng sẽ chuyện khoảng tình tòan nốt số tiền còn lại cho thành.
Tại cơ quan đều tra, đối tượng thành đá 2 hình tòa vụ hình viên 1 giới mại giâm của bản thân.
Hình hà mi sau tháng 1 năm 2020, các quan cạnh xa đổi trà công hán tình bác mình đã tự tổ hủ án hình dự,
hợp tổ bị gân và tạm giâm được với đối thân thành về hình viên 1 giới mại giâm.
Lông thời cùng của hồ sơ để sự phát bi phạm hình chính đối với các đối tượng của mạnh giâm,
hình có khoảng cạnh xa đổi trà công hán tình đang tích tục đều tra, sử lý theo của định.